[Music]
amanda is in lexington kentucky
hi amanda welcome to the dave ramsey
show hello
i'm so excited to talk to you thank you
so much you too what's up
um so my husband is in the md phd
program awesome and he has about yeah
no debt there um unfortunately we do
have other debt
elsewhere and we're just starting baby
step two
but as he's nearing the end he's going
to have to be going to
um interviews for residency programs
which will have to up front the money to
go on an
interview he has to go on interview for
different residents
how much money does it take to go
interview
well depending on where it is now i've
tried to look things up some people say
up to five thousand dollars
to save up i just didn't know if i
should pause baby step two
i'm confused are we going on a vacation
around the world or are we going to
interview someplace
no just just different interviews um but
they're not central so yeah so what it
don't take five grand you get in the car
and drive your butt up there to the
hampton inn and interview
okay okay spend a lot of money eat the
powdered eggs in the morning and come
back home
okay so wait a minute what does he make
he's making money in residency or no
he's applying for his residency
yes is he getting a stipend in his md
phd program
yes yes he is how much is a stipend
about 25 000.
okay and are you working outside the
home
and that's about 40. okay so we have 65
000
household income and he needs to go two
or three trips around
on the cheap and do some interviews yes
this is not this is not rocket science
just put yourself a little interview
money aside
but it shouldn't take five thousand
dollars i mean i don't know where he's
where he's going you're staying inside
the united states right
yes yes okay and so like where would he
go as an interview as an example
um i know that there's um
like wisconsin has a good program
there's that's probably the furthest
that he's
going to go possibly arizona uh
but that's like the farthest and then
the east coast is probably another
option for him
so couple southwest air tickets here
there in the hampton inn bill
okay all right that works for me yeah
that's right
i'm ready to get this taken care of just
get this debt taken care of so okay but
yeah i mean you say that
when did the interview when did the
interviews begin
so he's going to start his third year in
may
and his fourth year is when he does
interviews oh so we have
uh 12 months before we even need any
money for an interview
correct and how much debt do you have
now
we have about 75 not including our
mortgage okay
cool well there's no absolute stone cold
panic here
so just chunk a lot chunk along on the
75 let's just be
let's just keep making progress on it
and as we approach
time to start doing interview let's lay
out some actual
numbers say okay we're going to fly to
there here's what the ticket costs
here's what the hampton inn costs or
whoever it is right i don't know i mean
whatever holiday and i don't care
but the uh uh and uh you know
and so we need fifteen hundred dollars
for that weekend
and then we need okay and then we need
twelve hundred dollars for that other
weekend and then we're gonna drive to
this one so that one's gonna be 400
and uh you know and we just start to put
it together as we get closer and you can
pull that out of your budget
and slow your get out of debt a little
bit in order to pull that off
if you gra if he graduates and you are
not debt-free which i think is going to
happen
he's going to be okay because when he
gets in residency he's going to make
some money there
and right finishes up he's going to be
making big money and you're going to
clear this all up real quickly
the touchdown in your whole thing is the
brilliant story in yours is
he got med school free holy crap
md phd program is the best you just
became a doc for free well a lot of work
but for free brilliant brilliant